have you heard about the camel people
are freaking out about the camel
in Pakistan I let's take a look at the
camel and then we'll talk about the
camel
this is a that not a real camel
don't worry about that not some sort of
Star Wars camel this is a sculpture
a camel that that is going to cost the
US State Department
400 thousand dollars to put it are
American Embassy being built in Islam
Abad Pakistan
and it is causing and uproar the
so let's well let's first go to the
State Department official document
explaining why
this camel is worth $400 out about this
artist product is uniquely qualified
public art which will be presented in
the new embassy should reflect the
values a predominantly
Islamic country according to state
department okay that sounds fine to me
and just as little side note also in the
Bible and in the car on
they both use the metaphor of a camel
passing through the eye
a video for their some religious the
background there they're not just
randomly picking something
a but you know what the 400,000 seems
like a lot apparently we have some
economic problems here
and represented chasing che: pit he's
not happy about this
the american people have a right to know
that their tax dollars are being spent
responsibly especially for
art that the vast majority of US
citizens will never have the opportunity
to view and basically there's been a
whole big Twitter firestorm out there is
about everything
four hundred thousand dollars for a
camel a
mas your Persian for you know be about I
but yeah area of
world so take it away well first of all
it's kinda racist I think this
you have a camel art piece in Pakistan
that Saif al-adel like but you know what
you gonna go to Africa and put a
watermelon hey what do you what are we
doing here people state Department that
number one
and secondly I yes a lot of money I
shouldn't
I should have gotten into art yeah does
a cam on what your internet went yes
you know i i host a lot of art events
and on a few guys is comics got you know
what holiday beverage and artisan in the
money that they spend on so many things
and I'm just in there now BC because you
said in your I could have done that
yeah it's just paint on a canvas yeah I
but somehow this person became hot and
that's how much is worse at work and I'm
sure
we do what we do stand up a lot of time
to go I can do that but
paper this you're a lucky and Kia
courses to
cut your ear off and then your art value
yeah goes way up there and I know you're
a
you don't like to spend the money am i
right you like your strict
conservative when it comes to american
Honda money guy was like we were
I could be added that up what do you
think forty thousand dollars is too much
for this type of thing
well you know it's a camel I I just
thought like ghetto americans we pride
ourselves on knock-off
like I feel I can you give me like 10
grand I cambodia Campbell
particulars 400,000 out link if you take
the whole meal at a bit it's just like
it
stupid ceramic km all it's for its
return it was a real camera me yeah
that's what we should have said okay
with a real camera he was gonna pick it
just have a few camels when you arrive
at the embassy in pakistan and that's
when you really will go on in Pakistan
yellows yeah yep isn't part
morning as I wrote a catalytic role
hidden cam all are we gonna hide like
CI CIA by in highly cable that late at
night we're gonna solve through and be
like we're gonna
a bad guys pop up our I think that's
what it is that maybe that's why they're
carrying the MoneyGram there'll be a
good anywhere hey mister general
Musharraf yeah Pakistan feedback what is
what I that were here he's on trial
for the a pay general so-and-so hey what
do you think this camera hope for a week
every 30 what I would do it through it
I ever get this secret that's what it is
yeah I might be a Trojan can I do
anything I could think about was four
hundred thousand dollars and then my
purse my second thought was I
I'm we meet we have to be a sculptor
they are mourning yet clear
yeah I I knew we could bring it to the
NSA somehow
I is this what do you think the where
the government is only spending a shit
load of money on everything every
embassy
everywhere so I don't even think that
has anything to do with Pakistan and the
camel
like they're doing this all the time so
should we ever get upset about this or
she is this exactly what we should get
upset about that word is pissing money
away everywhere
as long as we don't have to mention Ben
Ghazi alright then I think we're far
right maybe they're trying to be like
a well who's gonna run how do we get out
at the bank got the letter do for two
thousand dollars and a cam one another
and whatever they are they said if they
have some sorta budget set aside more
RNN at napolis got a call about yet no
tax yet
yeah but that well and also it said but
the form two thousand dollar price tag
actually very reduced price for Kenneth
Cole sure like I think
area which I really find that hard to
believe anyone DB US government a
reduced price 0 NE had the US government
ever bought anything at a reduced price
you know they do they mean I V up but
this guy is saying is with that whether
that's with that will blow your mind you
like what some
some a whole made even more for the cam
albright but they're like yet we gotta
pick up a separate them up with the
whole needle metaphor obviously you know
me like they're like alright well the
camels and want to stick am above with
chicken noodle and then
you know I bring in from the Bible the
correct like I just can't like that's
culture we going with great all day
within your means I have it written
right here so if the if the camel
contemplating needle I which is
a it's a camera fiberglass and to play
on the New Testament phrase
about the difficulty that the wealthy
had entering heaven
course the wealthy are the only ones
that can afford to 400,000 I camel
so I don't know that slaughter are
needed art it wasn't thinking about this
when you like busted out a cam all
you know in a minute but we then we're
like our look at the nato and make this
work like he was just like I'm gonna
make it came over to play we just said
is is true it's like that it is is this
metaphor
like you know the poor shall inherit the
earth but only the rich can actually
stop by the pool Campbell
I could write in that interesting yeah
better for you can afford that you guys
can never be able to afford this cable
I'll is this a really good argument
though seriously for for lowering taxes
because we
just put and with tax money and
everything and they just piss away
so is this could this be something I
could see the republican first look at
it
Pakistan that scares people but then
also been saying
well see where they're pissing your
money away and I think this is the type
thing that people might be like yeah
we shouldn't be doing it well the
question becomes again what is it like
if they've got a real budget set aside
for if they were like a thing where they
get you guys know
like colleges were sometimes a we have
to hire performers because we have
this money set aside and will use it we
lose it
yes so maybe that's it was that
situation with the guys like I have to
spend forty thousand what we find that
got a camel
is a girls get the camel even care your
care
if this that situation that then then we
we gotta go in Goa why are we putting
such a big budget on
art at the embassy in pakistan %uh the
the wanna make them if you look nice
get the pictures of president since
their but
you know I don't know